okay amazingly wearing holt's clothes is
our best option
everyone prepare to enter high society
okay how's everybody feeling anyone else
have the weird urge to lecture
themselves
peralta what are you doing peralta what
are you doing
i conjured him what the hell is going on
according to the community center
calendar amateur ballroom dancing
competition
ah okay i know how we're gonna blend in
don't say thrift store thrift store
[Music]
jake the overwhelming time pressure yep
hey where you going to the dance contest
i am nationally recognized fox trotter
dave blathus and these are my proteges
rhonda shawarma and hank frankel i don't
care who you are
upstairs is closed to the public fine
but we didn't have to endure this crap
when we danced in barcelona
the hearing's starting any seconds there
might be another staircase off the dance
floor
i'll sign us up for the contest good
idea oh and amy
your dress makes you look like a mermaid
we should try to blend in stretch your
leg up over your head
stretch your leg up over your head you
think i wouldn't if i could
oh looks like the captain found a
partner
good lord okay we begin with the free
dance period
to the spicy sounds of humber
all right the linoleum awaits my dear
oh boy i know we're undercover but i'm
starting to get real nervous about this
contest
you need to see a therapist let's dance
this way
how did you manage to step on both of my
feet at the same time i'm horrible at
this when can we stop
i'm horrible at this one no i know title
of my sex tape
yeah well done title of my sex tape
oh my god the captain he could really
win this thing
how did you get so amazing at dancing
jake focus
i found a back stairway over here and
spin
who is he here we go
hello everyone my name is roger
strikewell and i will be your guest
auctioneer this evening
so many faces to look at i won a radio
contest
and i'm so excited to be here tonight to
sell you all of these cool old greek
things
our first item up for bid is lot number
344.
it is this old vase vows if you're nasty
it was made in the year five
and depicts the classic greek fable
boy meets girl boy has goat legs and on
the back
just a whole bunch of wheat so let's
start the bidding at
ten dollars k started way too low i have
85 do i have 90.
i have 90 from the man with the face at
table four
this is terrible you don't know what
you're doing adam sandler
yeah that's right i collect antiquities
i'm a serious person
i'm writing a movie right now about the
russian revolution oh really who does
kevin james play in it
aha it's a serious movie trotsky
ah there it is but he's got a wife who
never wears a bra i think you're gonna
like it
thanks for dressing up by the way all
right back to this plate i think you
could use it for a variety of things
new item up there uh how much you guys
want to pay for me to stick my socks in
this moron's mouth
i will did football legend joe theismann
just bid a thousand dollars to put a
sock in my mouth
you bet okay but let's get it going a
little seriously back to the porno
please
uh 1200 bucks socking them out boom okay
the idiot gets ready
i'd say 1300 would be even better 1300
joel deisman coming in stores oh i got
39 25 000.
sold to joey this man congratulations
you're getting a sock in your mouth 1300
bucks joe theismann can i stick the sock
in his mouth i'll pay extra
yes you may because i just sold my item
to the man in the great shirt at table
18.
nypd you're under arrest heading your
way
[Music]
gotcha my leg my leg
you broke my other leg uh
oh this was supposed to be a safe event
nothing to see here
except for the bone oh sticking out of
the leg
joe i videoed it
[Music]
okay how do i look like i'm about to buy
a bunch of expensive art hell yeah
and not just paintings either you look
statue rich
i was hoping that my best man duties
would be all whiskey and cigars but this
is charles we're talking about so we've
got two straight days of wedding
planning
plus he gave me this to prep fancy broad
gum
it means fancy groom and danish
according to charles the danes throw the
most beautiful weddings in the world
and the most violent funerals
this does not look like something you'd
be into normally yes but i am now
charles's fur
best man danish so it is my duty to
support him no matter what weird crazy
charlesy ideas he has
okay be kind i don't have a model's body
like you come on show what you got
fred astaire gene kelly liberace diane
keaton
roger that
okay charles you're not scottish
yeah get back in there braveheart summer
linen suit
casual but classic actually not bad
one question can you see my underwear ah
thong
why are you wearing a thong it's why
something borrowed
get back in there apparently the tsar of
russia gave that bejeweled egg to his
girlfriend as a present
i've never gotten a bejeweled anything
stupid then i guess we'll have to
transform ourselves
into the uber wealthy
charles turn that music off oh sorry i
was just practicing in case you guys
changed your mind
okay we're about to walk into the land
of money remember all rich people are
monsters so unleash the beast got it
[Music]
open it good afternoon may i help you
we're here all the time get familiar
with these faces or get familiar with
the unemployment line
i'm so sorry but i have to check you in
i need a member number i don't
have my member number with me it's too
bad you can't just use my amex black
card oh that's great
we can use that you can well you think i
carry around my own wallet
[Laughter]
i'm sorry sir if you could just give me
a name that would be great
i'll give you a name pamplemoose lacroix
i'm so sorry miss lacroix you're not in
the system
this is ridiculous you know what call
daddy daddy'll get us in
daddy the man won't let us into the club
yes daddy
no daddy no daddy wants to speak with
you gladly
hello daddy yes daddy no daddy
daddy oh well good question daddy daddy
wants to get this young man fired what
is your first and last name
uh you know what forget about it you can
just go on up fantastic
everything's well daddy we're heading in
daddy
you